━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
内藤忍の資産デザイン研究所メール＜第七百号2026年9月4日（金）発行＞
資産デザイン研究所メールは、資産運用に役立つ情報を個人投資家の皆様に提供するウィークリー・メールマガジンです。
金融資産だけではなく、不動産をはじめとする実物資産への投資まで、幅広い投資対象を組み合わせる「ハイブリッド投資」の具体的方法を可能な限り客観的な視点でご紹介いたします。
資産デザイン研究所
内藤忍公式ブログ
内藤忍、株式会社資産デザイン研究所は、資産配分などの投資アドバイスは行いますが、金融商品の勧誘・推奨などの投資助言業務は一切行っておりません。
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
【残席6名】【無料】金利上昇で不動産投資しても大丈夫？
と心配する人のためのセミナー（9/14）
12年続く毎回好評の定番セミナー
9月も追加開催決定です
10名限定で東京ミッドタウン六本木で開催
今回は金利上昇下での不動産投資について情報提供いたします
現在の環境下で失敗しない物件の選び方、お金の借り方がわかります
不動産投資未経験者・初心者におススメです
詳しい内容とお申込みはこちらから
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
1　資産デザインのすすめ　〜　こんしゅうの気になるテーマ
2　本気でやる資産運用　〜　セミナー・勉強会のお知らせ
3　読者の質問コーナー
4　内藤忍の「白米ダイエット日記」
5　資産運用日記
6　内藤忍のつぶやき
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
＜内藤忍の公式ブログ Shinoby`s World コラムタイトル一覧＞
毎日更新している公式ブログの、前回メールマガジン配信以降のコラムです。
こちらから全文をお読みいただけます
8月29日 「ライスワーク」だけは65歳に関係なくリタイアしたい
8月30日 晴海フラッグの「BRT東京駅ルート」より先にやって欲しいこと
8月31日 真逆な投資手法の「白服大家」さんと意気投合した理由
9月1日 ドジャースタジアムで始球式をする日本人
9月2日 エアポート投稿おじさんのテンションを上げる「センチュリオンラウンジ」
9月3日 米系航空会社の機内食はなぜ「がっかり」なのか？
9月4日 「みんなで大家さん」のトラブルを嗤う人たちの「あしたは我が身」
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
＜内藤忍のメディア出演・出版情報＞
【毎月更新】マネックス証券の投資情報サイト「マネクリ」
最新コラムタイトルは
「定期的なインカム収入が欲しいなら、高コストな毎月分配型ファンドではなく定期解約サービスを」
連載一覧はこちらから
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
1　資産デザインのすすめ〜こんしゅうの気になるテーマ
ベッセント財務長官が動かす為替相場
こんしゅう再び為替マーケットが大きく動きました。
そのキーパーソンは今回もベッセント財務長官です。
日銀の植田総裁がベッセント氏との会談後に利上げを加速させることを示唆し、マーケットに疑心暗鬼が広がりました。
ドル円の為替レートは短期間に4円以上円高に振れていますが、次の目安となるのは前回の円高局面の1ドル＝155円を超えた円高が進むかどうかです。
日米当局の足並みを揃えた円安是正への断固とした動きが円を借りてドルを買うキャリートレードのポジション縮小を加速させれば、大幅な円高の可能性も出てきます。
しかし、日銀が利上げを続けられるのかは国内経済の動向も無視できません。
アメリカの利上げによる金利差拡大も円安要因として機能します。
為替マーケットはしばらく神経質な動きが続きそうです。
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
2　本気でやる資産運用　〜　セミナー・イベントのご案内
【残席6名】【無料】金利上昇で不動産投資しても大丈夫？
と心配する人のためのセミナー（9/14）
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
3　読者の質問コーナー
読者からのご質問に、内藤忍がズバリ回答いたします！
Ｑ：金利が上昇し、株価や不動産にも悪影響が出そうです。
為替も不安定な動きになってきており、外貨投資も慎重にせざるを得ません。
これから何に投資したら良いのでしょうか？
Ａ：ご質問ありがとうございます。
確かに、現在の投資を取り巻く環境は厳しくなっている事は事実です。
しかし、こんごもインフレが続くと予想されインフレ率に以上に資産を増やしていく方法を検討しなければなりません。
まず考えられるのが、インフレ率を超えるようなインカム型の資産です。
ソフトバンクの社債が4パーセントを超えるということで話題になっていますが、それよりも高金利の未じょうじょう企業が発行する私募債であれば2桁の利回りを実現できるものもあります。
また、金利はつきませんがインフレに強い資産を持つのも1つの方法です。
現金を保有する代わりにアンティークコインや日本刀といったこんご価値の上昇が見込まれる資産を保有するのもインフレヘッジとして有効です。
どのような投資環境になっても変わらないのは分散投資の重要性です。
将来のマーケット環境を当てに行くのではなく、どのような環境になっても大きなダメージを受けないようなバランスの取れたポートフォリオを構築し続けるようにしましょう。
このコーナーでは読者の方からのご質問に、資産デザイン研究所だいひょう取締役の内藤忍がメールマガジン上で回答いたします。
資産デザイン研究所
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
4　内藤忍の「白米ダイエット日記」
福岡に行ったらもつ鍋も良いけど「もつすき」を
しばらく東京を離れていたので、今回は東京ではなく福岡の美味しいお店を紹介したいと思います。
福岡と言えば豚骨ラーメンやもつ鍋が名物ですが、同じもつでも鍋ではなくすき焼きにして食べさせてくれるお店に出かけました。
店内はカジュアルな雰囲気でお座敷席に案内されました。
センマイのお刺身や酢もつなどの前菜を頼んでからいよいよメインの「もつすき」です。
もつのすき焼きは店主が席で調理をしてくれます。
まずは鉄鍋にスライスしたニンニクと新鮮なホルモンを入れ炒めます。
ホルモンはマルチョウ、ハツ、センマイ、ミノなどがミックスされています。
そこに日本酒を大量に投入し、火をつけてアルコールを飛ばします。
炎が上がるフランベでテンションが上がります。
さいしょはもつだけを味わいます。
テーブルに置いてある七味にんにくというインパクトのある調味料を好みでふりかけて食べると臭みの抜けたプリプリのホルモンが甘辛くなって箸が止まりません。
もつは思わずおかわりをしてしまいました。
その後に続くのが旨味を吸わせる野菜たちです。
ホルモンの旨味が凝縮された鍋にキャベツ、ニラ、豆腐などを投入して、スープをしっかり吸わせます。
野菜の旨味も相まって何とも絶妙な味加減です。
野菜や豆腐なのでたくさん食べてももたれません。
こちらも迷わずおかわりです。
かなりお腹がいっぱいになったところでさいごは〆のちゃんぽんです。
これがまた最高の味わいでお腹が膨れているのになぜかスルスルと食べられてしまいます。
美味しく完食できました。
福岡にはもつ鍋のお店はたくさんありますが、もつすきのお店は他には見たことがありません。
是非一度出かけてみることをおススメします。
今回は直前でも予約が取れましたが、満席になることもあるので事前予約がおススメです。
福岡にまた行く機会があったら絶対にリピートしたい。
それくらい気に入りました。
もつ繁
福岡県福岡市中央区赤坂2-3-27
092-761-3497
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。